20 millones de vacunas para donar a
través del mecanismo kóvacs es el
anuncio que hizo ayer lunes el
presidente estadounidense joe biden que
suma a los 60 millones de dosis de
astrazéneca prometidas anteriormente y
que no están siendo usadas en el país
pues no han recibido el visto bueno de
la fd a este nuevo paquete de ayuda
incluye dosis de facer modernas y
johnson and johnson propiciado por la
cada vez menor demanda en eeuu
compartiremos estas vacunas para poner
fin a la pandemia en todas partes no
usaremos nuestras vacunas para asegurar
favores de otros países y trabajaremos
con kóvacs el mecanismo internacional y
otros socios para asegurar que las
vacunas sean entregadas de manera
equitativa y siguiendo la ciencia y los
datos de salud pública director general
de la oms agradeció el gesto de
washington no sin antes haber denunciado
que el mundo está en un apartheid de
vacunas por la desigual distribución el
mundo está en una parte de vacunación
como saben los países de altos ingresos
tienen el 15 por ciento de la población
mundial pero acumulan el 45 por ciento
de las vacunas y los países de ingresos
medios y bajos tienen la mitad de la
población mundial pero sólo han recibido
17% de las vacunas disponibles para el
continente americano eeuu ha vacunado al
47 por ciento de su población sobre un
total de casi 330 millones una brecha
significativa con países de américa
latina como colombia que tan solo ha
vacunado al 89 por ciento de sus
ciudadanos sobre poco más de 50 millones
el anuncio de joe biden se da en el
marco de un debate recientemente abierto
sobre la propuesta de liberar
temporalmente a las patentes de las
vacunas con miras a producir más
fármacos para combatir la pandemia una
medida que países como alemania rechazan
pero el propio bardem ha respaldado